je pense que c'est un petit peu plus
Jean-Michel Cohen il a pas menti là bien
sûr il dit exactement
s'il gagne effectivement un salaire de
médecin 7000 et 13000 € de livres c'est
extraordinaire ça veut dire qu'ils vont
énormément de livres et tant mieux pour
lui si c'était pas le bon chiffre il ne
le dirait pas ce qu'on est Jean-Michel
Cohen Mathieu là c'est faux franchement
vous avez tort oui Delphine ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'aujourd'hui les gens
sont de plus en plus libre et ils
existent tout ils exilent leur vie ils
exubé leur enfant ils exigent leur corps
et la seule chose dont on parle pas
c'est l'argent donc ça aussi j'espère
que ça va venir parce qu'en France
aujourd'hui il faut être fier que quand
on travaille bien qu'on gagne bien sa
vie et et
non non Jordan et Jordan je voulais le
féliciter parce que toutes les personnes
qui passent chez lui
parce qu'en fait tu es persuadé que
personne ne te regarde et non mais c'est
non mais en fait et non parce que Jordan
est très regardé non mais je vous dis
est très repris donc en fait c'est ça tu
arrives tu dis en plus tu vois le nom
Jordan de luxe tu as l'impression d'être
au McDo non mais c'est ça tu vois en
fait tu dis du avec des conneries tu dis
ouais tu vois voilà ça met ça passe pas
ça passe et bah si bah bravo mon Jordan
on a fait cette séquence de ce pour
arriver à Benjamin Castaldi
donc il faut non il faut jamais dire
combien on gagne par mois évidemment
vous l'avez fait je l'ai fait j'ai eu
tort j'ai fait il y a 15 ans vous avez
dit combien on a 15 ans je dis la vérité
moi je gagnais très très bien moi vous
avez dit j'ai dû gagner dans les 200000
€ par mois à peu près 200000 € par mois
par mois oui bien sûr
de 2 millions 200000 € par an à peu près
combien d'années deux trois ans ça a
duré 3 ans 3 ans ça fait 6 millions 6000
vous avez bien compris c'est mignon si
t'as donné 3 millions d'impôts 2
millions
800 impôts donc ce qui veut dire qu'il
te reste mon chéri il t'a il me restait
non il te restait trois il te reste donc
tu enlèves 6 6 - 8 - 2 voilà il me
restait à peu près
4 4
voilà après vous achetez une voiture
vous achetez une voiture de voiture en
voiture quelle voiture alors avec 4 4
tu vas manger tu vas manger 5 ou 6 fois
voilà non mais c'est non mais j'étais
sur les quatre quatre il y a plus rien
non il est plein sur les 4 millions 4
terminaux non terminé maintenant
j'ai investi j'adore ce sujet moi
j'avais acheté j'avais acheté une maison
une maison de campagne un appartement ça
doit être sûr
non mais tu les revends
tu as gagné combien à peu près 10
en tout dans toute ma carrière
j'avais fait les calculs j'ai quelques
avais donné 10 millions au fisc donc
j'ai dû gagner pas mal
ils sont dans ton cul
[Applaudissements]
terminé vous le savez Cyril non mais non
mais attends non non tu as dû gagner 22
millions
vous êtes choqué pour 12 bars
ton salaire Benjamin tu es sûr que c'est
pas plus parce que non non non non non
non non non non
position c'est bien Béatrice c'est bon
mais c'est normal bah écoutez il y aura
pas d'augmentation mais c'est normal
vous venez d'arriver et puis voilà
et voilà j'avais raison après juste
derrière il y a un palier et
franchement je suis étonné Delphine
dans le noyau dur
ensuite Géraldine
et là c'est là que je suis complètement
fou il y a à peu près il y a Valérie
Gilles
surtout pour vous et en premier Mathieu
Benjamin
et Delphine
voilà
je le dis voilà je vous dis que
la merde
pour l'instant c'est la première saison
où je serai augmenté au bout de la
troisième ou 4e de demander l'heure voir
cinquième saison c'est vraiment eux ils
ont pas bouger voilà depuis longtemps et
ils bougeront jamais